What in the fuck is that $5,000 a pound?
Japan's King of tuna.
Is that racist? Is that racist? Uh,
the way I said it, it seemed racist.
Uh, the first tune auction of the year,
a Tokyo's new fish market set a record
price more than 3 million for a giant
Bluefin tuna, a critically
endangered species. Wow. Yeah.
See that's where you gotta go, man. Is
he critically endangered? And if it's,
if it is, so should you really
be cutting that fucker up?
I don't know about that. When I
was in Hawaii, uh, we caught some,
uh, yellowtail my youngest daughter loves
fishing, so went out with her and we, uh,
went on this boat and we
were actually jigging.
There's like this shelf in this big drop
off in these yellow tails hanging out
there.
And we caught a gang of them.
And one of the things they were saying
was that the big island had a farm where
they were farming yellowtail.
Like they had this gigantic,
like sort of netted in area where the
fish couldn't leave and they were,
they were trapped in this area.
But then the storm came and broke down
all the nets and the fish escaped and now
they're everywhere and you're
catching them. We caught like, oh,
I'm like six or seven of them and they're
fucking pig like 10 pounds and you're
fighting them on like a light,
a spinning rods,
like really awesome, awesome time.
But they were unbelievably delicious,
but these are non native.
They brought him over there
and released him and I'm like,
they've been our start doing
that with other fish right there.
Really should set up these fish farms
and just released these motherfuckers out
into the ocean because they're just
taking nets and pulling them across the
bottom of the [inaudible]
Lauren even,
it's like such a,
there's something to be said about
going out and catching the fish,
like you're saying,
rather than taking a net and just scooping
everything up in its path. Everything.
Yeah,
turtles, dolphins, whatever the fuck
is there. Everything gets jacked.
And the problem is, you know, there's,
who knows how many countries have boats
that are doing that and they're all
operating in international water. And
I don't know what the fucking laws are,
but they're just pull in what any,
you know the other thing they do
that's fucked up when they're done.
A lot of times they cut the, the net
loose and they just leave it in the ocean.
They just dropped the net
to the bottom of the ocean.
It's funny they have the
regulations for like hunting. Yeah.
They don't have it like in the ocean,
you know it's because nobody owns it.
You only own like a certain,
I'm out of your shore.
Like I'll off like say from Malibu out.
I don't know how much they
the United States owns,
but we only own a certain amount and
then it becomes international waters,
international waters. It's like kind of
anybody could be out there. It's weird.
I mean it makes sense but there's no,
I don't think there's any,
I think if you have a boat you
can just kind of go anywhere.
That's international water, just
no regulations here. What is,
what parts of the ocean are
considered international water?
Territorial waters or seas defined by
a 1982 United Nations convention on the
Law of the sea.
It's a belt of coastal waters extending
at most 12 nautical miles from the
baseline. Usually the mean low
water mark of the coastal state.
So 12 miles or 12 miles out,
or a 13.8 miles nautical miles.
Nautical miles is different. Huh? Hm.
Interesting.
Why is it different or weird?
Is that nautical miles is different than
regular miles? The fuck get it together.
Yeah. Don't call it a mile then
he fucks. Imagine, hey buddy,
I'll meet you at 12 miles.
All right.
12 nautical miles and the guys
at mile on a 0.8 away from you.
Although stores use the
label Sushi grade fish,
there is no official standards
for using this label.
The only regulation is that
parasitic fish such as salmon,
should be frozen to kill any
parasites for being consumed raw.
The best ones are assigned grade one,
which is usually what
be sold as Sushi grade.
But what about Sashimi grade is
when he said it's the same thing.
So I looked up and that's what popped up.
Yeah.
You're not supposed to eat salmon raw.
Apparently salmon is a freshwater
fish and salmon. It can fuck you up,
but you could pull a tune out of
the right out of the ocean. Yeah.
I have a buddy of mine who when
a tuna fishing off of San Diego,
they call it a tuna and they sliced it
up and ate it right there on the boat.
Like right as they read after
they pulled it out of the water.
That I haven't done, but uh, that,
that to me would be the bus eating
right out of the water. I mean,
I just hope they don't wait until there's
nothing left before they start doing
something to save them. It just doesn't,
it doesn't seem like the, I mean,
if you're taking us fish and
you're buying it for $3 million,
that's almost like a scene in the
movie. Right. That's like the end.
This was one of the last tune I looked.
They bought it for 3 million.
Everybody's smiling and
they're cutting it up.
It's like hunting regulations
are critical, but you could,
you know what the population
is. It's very, they, they do.
The fish and wildlife departments have
all these different methods they use,
whether it's, I'm using reports from
Hunter's, whether it's uh, they,
they fly over with airplanes and
helicopters and things along those lines.
Whatever they use.
They have a bunch of different ways that
they can determine what the population
is. Then they had determined
the population of predators,
how many animals are lost,
how many animals are our shot
during any hunting season.
And then they determine how
many tags can be divvied out.
So like say if you live in an area,
um,
there might be a 500 tags available,
but there might be like 2000 hunters
that are applying for those tags.
So most people are not going
to get it. It's a, it's a,
a very smart way. They've really got
it down to a science because of that.
There's more white tail
deer in this country than,
than even when Columbus landed. Yeah,
it's a, they've got a really good system.
If they could figure
something out for the ocean.
The problem is you'd have to get
everybody to cooperate in some,
like they can't even get Japan to
stop killing whales. Like there's,
there's certain Japanese folks who,
uh,
they have this really sneaky thing they
do and there's this, there's this, um, um,
conservation group called
the sea shepherds and they
catch these fucking people
all the time.
But what they basically do is they say
we're a research boat and they use a
research boat and go slaughter
whales and then sell the whales.
But they pretend that it's, that it's
research, but if they kill a whale,
certain countries still value parts
of Wales. They make things with it.
What the fuck did they make with whales?
I think they make some perfumes.
Like what? But people are
still killing whales. It gets,
it gets weird when things are smart.
That's when it gets weird. Yeah. You know,
something as smart as a fucking whale.
Yeah. I mean, uh, the end,
these, in these countries,
the, they're using, like you
said, parts of the fish for,
you know, they put it on their
mantle. They got like a a, I dunno,
a tooth or, or what have you
found from a whale or a shark
or whatever it is.
That's the big thing with rhinos.
Guys cut the rhino horns off and they
drink it like in a tea and supposed to
make your dick hard.
Oh, is, see, this is what I'm talking
about. You know, these things.
I mean, I don't know how the hell you
remember all this stuff. I'm going to,
I've just forgot the mileage
off the coast. Great. Now,
13.8 models. Miles 12 nautical
miles. One point difference.
1.8 difference at 12 miles, which is, who
knows how long you get to 500 miles out.
You gotta do the math. It's crazy.
It's stupid. Yeah. Um, yeah.
I don't know how I remember these things.
It's a fucking screw we brain.
I wish I had your memory, Joe.
That's what I'm saying. It's
not the best. I'm telling you.
It's like there's still a lot
of shit that I don't remember.
I just remember things that are
interesting. You know, I have, uh,
it's, it's an odd, it's an odd
sense of memory, but the, uh,
the Rhino Horn thing is kind of sad
because it doesn't even work, you know,
especially in this day and age where
people can get Viagra. It works. Yeah.
But there's something about it,
I think in some Asian cultures where
it's considered like a sign of wealth.
You drive a Rolls Royce, you drink
rhino t this guy's a baller. You know,
he doesn't give a fuck. He drinks
wine, Ot, you know, like, Oh man,
guys drinking rhino t what a guy. Yeah.
This, but there's something about that,
like, you know, yeah, I want
to eat an extinct animal.
I want to bring a woolly mammoth back
to life and shoot it in the head.
Like there's some people that
are like that. Like, they,
they want to be the ultimate conqueror
and you know, I want to eat a whale dick.
You know what I mean? Like this.
There's people that are like, that.